did it work did it scare you I hope it
did if it didn't scare you I would be
very upset they're they're upset it is
tiny it is teeny tiny and I don't seem
to have a way to me it is literally tiny
oh my god is this really it it's so tiny
wait Han I gotta change this hang on
yeah let's do this that way I also get
the desktop if something goes in I can
turn that off okay behind-the-scenes
stuff is done lik seeing high five we're
in a concerted effort and a team yeah
this game also did I say the name of
this game this game is called discover
my body in the year 2040 human beings
look for increasingly strange solutions
in hopes to find a connection and
community distrusting previous
institutions that supposedly brought
people together in common lonely people
look to technology and science for
answers one such new technology is a
psychically powerful lab synthesized
fungi you a medical student at the local
university have been brought in to study
its application to a host human oh [ __ ]
ah you must be the new student dr.
Morrison was speaking of I hear you
really quite bright oh I hear you're
quite bright have you ever studied this
a psychical physical no psychical trans
bola tution flowering before I see well
you're in for quite a treat I have
assisted with many flowerings before
however this is my first time in the hot
seat
this facility is equipped with a neutron
coronal scanner you'll be able to view
my transformation oh and its various
effects on my bodily systems just
navigate the icon over my body and scan
for info points to click on my brains
Broca area has been linked to a digital
readout so even when I am at the point
where I am beyond human speech I will be
able to communicate well please begin
your examination
Oh Oh I don't want to see your body this
close oh no no no no no no no no oh no I
don't like it oh I do not want to see
your body this close
I'll please tell me there isn't going to
be a pain here oh you're covering okay
thank goodness gracious you're covering
your beanie peen
I was almost demonetised okay good great
Oh what's with your medusa head that's a
little strange skin Oh aha
you've discovered the injection site two
weeks ago dr. Morrison took a bone deep
needle to my right shin it hurts like
hell however what he injected was worth
its weight in gold it was a skin graft
of a successful ptb flowering what's
that it kind of looks like a face well
the PTB organism is a psychic Lee is a
psychical organism it's physical
manifestation draws from a shared pool
of all its denizens traumas fears dreams
I believe that's my mother's face on my
shin totally normal
I get it I get your pain and trauma your
mom very strange oh how I miss her not
anymore it's a beautiful thing but
enough about me please continue the
examination oh I'm an eager beaver for
this let's inspect the junky wonky nope
nope how about the TomTom how about the
elbow how about the other bow
how about the nipping up how about the
other boobie will be blue how about that
neck II wacky you got your real boring
man
skeletal haha you've discovered my
rotting bones yes the Rada said in
certainly it itches like the devil but
soft bones are required for the ppb to
do its work the human body was never
intended to experience a flowering no I
don't think so no in the process one is
contorted psychically and physically
soft rotting bones are pliable enough to
assume a flower in shape again though
very painful stuff when I begin to
scream I expect you to keep your cool
though yeah this should all be academic
do you yeah are you getting any class
credit for this by the way I see Wow
please continue yeah no I'm not in
college at the moment I am far beyond
that I have ascended to another level
beyond the educational system one could
say that I have flowered like a tree
beyond out of my rotting bones whatever
house this tourney Wernham nice Scully
whoa interesting
aha you've discovered the primordial
inhibitor Oh curse I have you daft
bastard the primordial inhibitor this is
a device implanted in my brainstem which
helps to undo certain evolutionary 56
cards against operations like this yeah
your ancestors are calling you dumb ass
from way beyond the grave it limits
bodily and mental reactivity to meta
existential stimuli and not too many
words the flowering is an evolutionary
aberration definitely something we want
to do talk to your mom about it she says
it's all good oh thanks leg mom great
one which requires some retooling of our
formation of mental concepts for
instance one who has flower does not
experience the human idea of time but if
I tried and apprehended this with my
regular old monkey mind you know my big
dumb hee-hoo brain I would go quite and
say no but anyway please go on discover
explore look at my penis ah according to
the concentration of the BTP in my blood
I will begin the flowering process very
soon quick give me your wallet to buy
this is a pretty roundabout way to steal
my wallet
[Laughter]
I would just give it to you I would
without question and I'm gonna do that
now holy [ __ ]
Wow that hurt sorry I seem to have bit
down too hard and broken a couple teeth
give me a moment to spit them out
[Music]
now then as you can see by my face
I am midway through the flowering
process hurrah I can feel the inkling of
a pan psychic connection and my body has
experienced amazing and terrible growth
see for yourself
oh okay righty-ho how's your growth
oh good growth oh good oh wow why are
you doing this who is that your pop ha
your father oh no where'd mama go okay
good what is this sack what's going on
here
[Music]
aha you've discovered that my hands have
fallen off well I suppose I'll never
play the violin again
hahaha joking aside this is pretty much
to be expected part of the primordial
inhibitor is to dissociate brain and
hand connectedness as a result of this
the hands fall off as they are merely
vestigial baggage standing in the way of
a superior evolution I'm sorry just
briefly had a bit of ego death there for
a moment I can feel my thoughts
intertwine in the rhizomatic group mind
please continue of course I understand
perfectly what you're talking about oh
my goodness
something's wrong with your skeleton or
something's very right
aha you've discovered my bone growth
you're not gonna have a fancy name for
that one it's gonna leave it at bone
growths yes of course your bone growth
as I was saying about the dramatic
changes of BTB flowering in curse well
now had a bone deep level my skeletal
system is basically sponge cake ha ha ha
dig in ha ha don't ok but look closer my
bone fragments have begun to reassemble
into a complicated if fragile lattice
work of wafer thin psychic receptors
some of the bones are poking out of my
skin I knew that I felt it ha ha ha ha
did you see it please go on
all right your brain seems to be
shrinking your brains a bit smaller
dinky brain we got small brain over here
[ __ ] hee hoo brain am i right
everybody what a what a biologically
uninhibited individual not like us who
have our glorious psycho actively
inhibited biological receptors what a
[ __ ] peanut all right anyway found
something
aha you've discovered my new minds Oh to
the extent that the brain is a mind that
is we'll leave that to the philosophers
as my own mind brain disintegrates into
the group mind what remains of my body
become a small distribution of other
flowering mind brains as we speak I am
flooded with powerful memories that are
not my own I feel well it's hard to even
use the word eye anymore even to
distinguish ourselves from our timeless
unity seems wrong
I feel infinite pleasure as well as
infinite is this what death is
aha I see we are at the final stages I
complete the flowering infinite pleasure
pain
I'm so happy
hey I'm glad I got to watch that I'm
happy for you I'll stick with my little
tiny hooey who brain guess I'll just
keep biting down on my wallet and hope
for change isn't that right mom that was
discovered my body that was awesome
really truly that was awesome James you
met good [ __ ] that was so imaginative
and so cool I want to see so much more
of that
just the way deadpanned such a bizarre
and horrifying transformation and just
like owned every second of it whoa loved
it loved it
keep making [ __ ] and if there's anything
else that you make in the future I am
going to play it because that was
awesome and if you guys at home want to
experience the true horror and wonder
that is discovering my body there's a
link in the description that'll take you
to the game ooh
you've found my like button what it does
is it creates a hive mind of aggregate
associative enjoyment out of this video
it collects all of our thoughts so we're
not just a dumb little hee-hoo brain
whoo you've discovered my subscribe
button it allows us to telepathically
communicate to know exactly when a new
videos coming out
you found Bible it's a psychic signal
that pings lightning fast between all of
our collective minds so you know the
instant one of my videos goes up on the
YouTube oh wow I can feel the BTB
flowing through my body
I'm about to ascend to the next level
give me your wallet